madame monsieur bon jouer à vis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique en bourgogne
aujourd'hui je reçois le maire de dijon
bonjour françois rebsamen
bonjour alors en toute confidence c'est
le livre que vous sortez mercredi 9
novembre aux éditions stock
alors qu'est ce qui vous prend est ce
que c'est un livre programme pour vous
aussi vous déclaré aux primaires
socialistes c'est un livre d'abord que
j'ai dédié à mon ami alain en souvenir
d'alain millau l'ancien maire de dijon
et je suis revenu à dijon suite à son
décès est encore quelques journalistes
par exemple ils n'ont pas compris donc
je le redis si j'ai quitté le mystère
c'est parce que il ya eu le décès de mon
ami alain donc j'ai voulu dédier ce
livre dans ce livre je dis que le
bonheur c'est quand vos actes sont en
dire en conformité avec vos paroles en
accord avec nos paroles c'est ce que t
as grandi et c'est ce que j'ai repris en
exergue donc c'est un livre où je fais
part de mes muses expérience j'essaie
d'en tirer quelques analyses et de faire
des propositions il ya beaucoup de
livres 1 en ce moment deux des
politiques ça fait dire à nos un de nos
internautes qui s'appelle atout coeur
qu'est ce qui peut bien pousser les
politiques à étaler leurs états d'âme
comme ça se passait pas un livre d'états
d'âme moi je sais pas un livre de ragots
c'est pas si je vais être clair je
crache pas dans la soupe
il ya suffisamment donc non je fais part
de mes réflexions des propositions pour
améliorer la vie publique
voilà un moment il est
le nécessaire je crois de faire le point
et puis de d'avancer des propositions -
c'est un livre qui je l'espère va
provoquer du débat alors le livre
commence par le jour de votre dernier
conseil des ministres moi je voudrais
qu'on remonte un petit peu avant vous
vous attendiez avec ministre de
l'intérieur en 2012 ça rate et un
françois hollande a choisi manuel valls
a été une énorme déception
vous voulez que je vous raconte ça non
mais je pense que ça a été une énorme a
sonné ça a été tout sauf à se préparer
les jeux wii jeu on m'a même reproché
d'être trop préparé c'est ce que
j'arrive donc je vais te préparer pour
être mises à terre quand on se prépare
pour un poste ministériel il faut y
travailler
donc j'avais préparé cela et ce en tant
que je n'aurai pas ce poste sans tant
que je n'aurai pas ce poste
eh bien j'ai pris la décision d'annoncer
moi même avant la composition du
gouvernement que je ne serai pas
ministre
et donc voilà je rêve je le dis j'aurais
pour l'amour que j'ai pour la ville de
dijon il ya que ce poste-là qui pouvait
me permettre de le quitter la ville de
dijon vous allez participer à la
constitution du gouvernement
oui vous avez proposé c'est vous qui
avez proposé christiane taubira vous
allez loin la non la révélation c'est
vrai dans le fameux livre un autre livre
un président ne devrais pas dire ça de
gérard davet david l'homme manuel valls
explique vous venez différents allusion
reps a du métier dit il mais je ne
voulais pas d'un sniper derrière moi dit
il se produit chez nous ce propos
langage voilà je veux pas de
commentaires à faire je commande palais
comme enfer il est prescrit si je vous
aurais dit en plus tu t'es trop tu
préparé il s'est un peu fichu d'où là si
je peux me permettre tous les cas c'est
comme ça que vous savez chacun sa vérité
de ces moments là c'est pas exactement
comme ça que j'ai vécu cet instant mais
je lui dit sa vérité
il a dit aussi qu'il voulait pas les
réseaux francs macs ça vous a blessé
surtout venons d'information finalement
vous allez accepter le ministère du
travail
finalement j'ai après avoir refusé
plusieurs postes accepté ce beau
ministère et de mystères du travail de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social et
parce que je pensais qu'il était de mon
devoir de participer à l'action de ce
gouvernement et je ne peux pas vous
pouvez pas rester en dehors de l'action
gouvernementale alors même que j'avais
tout fait pour que le président de la
république soit françois là on voit
quelques images de la passation de
pouvoir entre michel sapin et vous il
était très ému d'ailleurs michel sapin
sociaux social et puis à 17 mois après
hop passation de pouvoir dans l'autre
sens c'est myriam el khomri qui arrive
avec le recul c'est 17 mois de galère
non pas du tout non ces dix-sept mois
difficiles de ce 17 mois de travail
c'est à commenter des chiffres pas
toujours très à tous les mois je les dis
ça c'est un grand moment de solitude
je le dis d'ailleurs à celle qui m'a
succédé à myriam el khomri ça c'est le
moment le plus pénible parce que
finalement c'est pas le fruit de votre
travail mais il ya des moments de il ya
des moments de joie il ya des moments de
réussite moi j'ai fait je crois ce qui
restera comme innovant lois sociales je
sais qu'il va entraîner des élections
dans les tpe au cours du mois de
novembre et qui constituent les avancées
sociales importantes qui a été adoptée
149,3 donc sans le 49-3 donc comme quoi
il faut aussi savoir négocier par
renault chiffres de l'emploi vous allez
vous dit que vous n'y croyez pas à ces
chiffres de pôle emploi et puis là on
l'a vu à cette fois ci moins soixante
mille chômeurs vous auriez mais
peut-être les commenter cela moins 70
champions c'est non non non vous avez
même que c'est de la tendance était ça y
est ce que je refuse c'est le
commentaire mensuel qui ne veut
strictement cette fois ci j'ai pris du
recul en 10 ans depuis le début de
l'année il ya eu 90 mille chômeurs de
mois à pôle emploi est la véritable
mesure du chômage c'est le taux de
chômage qui est établi par l'insee le
bureau international du travail c'est à
dire ce qui sert de comparaison
internationale
ça me permet d'ailleurs de vous dire que
dans le bassin d'emploi de dijon le taux
de chômage au jour d'aujourd'hui est de
l'ordre de 8,2 pour cent et donc
étant en forte baisse dans forte baisse
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour notre
agglomération notre communauté urbaine
pendant votre passage au gouvernement
vous a taxé de dérive droitière
justement par rapport à votre loi par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit sur les
intermittents sur le contrôle des
chômeurs
vous l'avez mal vécu vous avez dit pour
vous défendre
ah mais le politiquement correct empêche
bien souvent de dire la vérité est ce
qu'est ce que c'est brest
alors d'abord les intermittents je crois
que avec le soutien du premier ministre
manuel valls j'ai résolu le problème des
intermittents avec la ministre à
l'époque de la culture fleur pellerin
j'ai effectivement fait adopter de
nouvelles règles d'indemnisation des
intermittents dont ils ne se plaignent
pas or quand les intermittents ne se
plaignent pas ça veut dire qu'ils sont
très contents voyez la différence et la
nuance
je les mets en garde sur ce qui pourrait
leur arriver demain parce que ils sont
pas toujours à remercier ils sont
souvent à critiquer c'est leur droit le
plus strict mais nous avons mis en place
avec leurs pèlerins un dispositif qu'ils
ont eux mêmes contribué la mort et est
donc ça c'est une première réussite
ensuite il ya eu la controverse sur les
chômeurs j'avais le contrôle
oui sur le contrôle je pense que j'avais
raison
bien évidemment sur ce sur ce sujet car
au sens du bureau international du
travail il y a une règle qui est simple
c'est que on est chômeur quand on
cherche du travail
voilà c'est une eau que les chômeurs
doivent faire preuve de leur volonté de
rechercher du travail et ça n'empêche
qu'on peut maintenir et les encourager
par la formation par un accompagnement
par une amélioration du dispositif c'est
ce que fait pôle emploi maintenant c'est
aussi une des mesures que j'avais prise
et je crois qu'ils en sont plutôt
satisfaits dérive droitière non
simplement via le politiquement correct
parisien qui s'imposent tous les jours
et celui là il empêche ce pays de se
réformer
mais alors finalement vous quittez donc
le ministère dans les circonstances que
l'on sait est-ce que vous en voulez à
françois hollande de ne pas vous a
permis de cumuler comme il l'a laissé
faire à jean yves le drian bretagne
non non je pense que ce n'était pas
possible moi je vous dire n'était pas
possible pour moi et il n'est pas
possible pour quelqu'un de faire comme
d'hab
man d'assurer convenablement la charge
aussi lourde de ministre du travail où
d'un ministère aussi important et une
fonction aussi importante que maire de
dijon et président de la communauté
urbaine n'est pas tant des gens et je
ris n'avait pas tenté non contrairement
à ce qui a été dit qu thomas ce qui
était dit j'ai simplement dit que le
lendemain je serai toujours ministre du
travail est maire légion parce que je
voulais avoir un délai descendent à moi
pour prendre mes marques
ce qui est d'ailleurs la règle en
matière après une élection en matière de
droits d'option est donc effectivement
j'ai annoncé je sais que c'était le 10
août j'ai annoncé que le 9 septembre je
ne serai plus ministre du travail et le
2 septembre je ne l'était plus et donc
j'aurai yves le drian
par delà le fait qu'il me dise de la
défense ce qui en temps de guerre et
quand même puisque j'ai entendu que nous
étions en guerre en tous les cas on est
en guerre contre le terrorisme
donc une responsabilité beaucoup plus
prégnante régaliennes que le ministère
du travail si important soit-il
donc il ya une présence mais il n'est
pas maire d'une grande ville
oui il est président il est président
d'une région et donc j'allais dire c'est
plus facile de se faire remplacer par
son premier vice-président que d'assumer
et une présidence de communauté urbaine
et une mairie le plus le plus surprenant
de danser quand vous voyez que on peut
être premier adjoint au maire de nice et
président de la région paca royan et
l'absence 3i lagat du cumul l'aïe a dû
cumuler des mauvaises positions et des
mauvaises dispositions d'ailleurs amoura
rapide à propos du cumul sur laurent
grandguillaume vous avez compris sa
position on a le sentiment que quelque
chose s'est cassé entre vous non non je
dis non non je respecte je respecte la
position de jeu j'ai le droit d'avoir
été surpris mais vous avez quand même
disait il s'est rendu compte que veut
être élu c'est pas facile
oui mais peut-être c'était à la hauteur
de ma surprise ce que j'ai dit mais j'ai
dit tout de suite d'ailleurs je respecte
sa décision
c'est quelqu'un qui a fait du bon
travail je pense qu'il aurait pu
continuer à faire du bon travail
d'ailleurs sa proposition de loi était
adopté hier au sénat à l'unanimité
donc moi je salue le travail qu'il a
fait
j'aurais préféré qu'ils continuent de le
faire c'est vrai je peux le dire comme
ça mais il faut respecter cette décision
est la sienne et vous avez laissé
entendre que vous pourriez de candidats
dans la première circonscription de
côte-d'or c'est celle où ça y est c'est
passé c'est ça ça me permettait de
ramener un peu de calme de sérénité
bon allez avant les législatives ya les
présidentielles vous répéter à qui veut
l'entendre françois hollande est le seul
qui puisse faire gagner la gauche en
est ce que c'est une blague non non je
n'en peux plus la popularité du
président la république n'est pas bon
c'est pas une plaisanterie non vous
savez on est dans un drôle de pays on
est dans un drôle de pays où président
de la république aujourd'hui est au
creux dans les sondages personne ne le
nie et moi et je suis premier à le
reconnaître mais quand je regarde le
programme de la droite
je veux dire ce programme il est
exactement celui de 1986 on peut pas
dire que c'est dit c'est dit voilà
solide pour les plus jeunes je disais
c'est l'ancêtre du medef et donc il n'a
pas pris une ride
il faut toujours supprimer l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune comme si
c'était absolument une obsession comme
si ceux qui avaient aujourd'hui l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune qu'ils
paient cet impôt était des gens qui
étaient dans une grande nécessité
ça rapporte 5 milliards 6 au budget de
l'état pourra me dire comment on fait
pour compenser mais ce programme de la
droite
les français n'en veulent pas descôteaux
pose la question français est ce que la
droite ferait mieux que la gauche qui va
pouvoir répondre non et après quand on
demandait ce que l'extrême droite ferait
mieux ils répondent encore plus non donc
on est dans une situation qui est la
suivante la gauche au pouvoir
aujourd'hui dans le creux la droite il
n'y croit pas les stands doit-il croit
pas il n'y croit pas donc la vérité
c'est que ce pays
la faute à qui ça ça mérite réflexion
peut-être un peu aux médias je vous le
dis peut-être à vous aussi bien sûr
beaucoup à nous peut-être aussi un peu
aux médias vous pouvez pas vous exonérer
pas vous les médias en général de leur
propre réflexion
ce pays est atteint je ne sais pas
pourquoi d'une dépression nerveuse
c'est un pays où on contrôle le
déclinisme le défaitisme comment vous
expliquez que même les bonnes nouvelles
de l'emploi de septembre le moral des
français qui remonte les ans elle
demande à être confirmé l'amélioration a
priori de la situation des entreprises
tous ap
ça n'a aucun effet sur la cote de
popularité de l'oeil de françois
hollande il ya qu'en france d'ailleurs
que il a pas une bonne cote de
popularité ce qui est étonnant c'est
vrai il est apprécié et reconnu
moi je l' ai vu d'ailleurs dans son
exercice dans sa relation avec des chefs
d'état étrangers j'ai pu l'apprécier
mais vous savez je vous le dis il ya une
tendance aujourd'hui on aime bien se
faire du mal en france j'entendais
l'autre jour j'étais dans un débat avec
un économiste monsieur touati pour pas
le citer et il disait il ya six millions
et demi de chômeurs en france
pourquoi six millions et demi même quand
on prend les pires chiffres a b c est qu
on additionne le tout on arrive à 5
millions 5
mais peut-être c'est mieux de dire si
miami ou 17 millions et plus ont dit des
choses qui nous dévalorise et plus on a
l'air heureux mais c'est à dire quelque
chose qui ne va pas donc il faut
rétablir la vérité il ne risque de se
faire humilier sylvain d'être éliminée
dès le premier tour
c'est son risque il doit le prendre
il doit assumer son bilan il doit
présenter un projet et donc moi je lui
dis tous les jours
il remontera vous savez l'élection
présidentielle elle n'est pas joué
contrairement à ce qu'on croit
aujourd'hui et je vous rappellerai pas
balladur chirac
je vous rappellerai pas dans quel état
était la popularité de françois hollande
au moment de la primaire de la gauche
n'ont rien rien rien d'accord il ya un
bon bilan
quand on verra quel est le candidat de
droite quand il sera obligé de dire quel
est son programme
quand il faudra dire où c'est qu'ils
suppriment 400000 emplois
enfin fonctionnaires à moins de faire
comme monsieur le maire qui considère
que les emplois d'avenir sont des
fonctionnaires et entendu l'autre jour
on a un débat à droite qui et j'allais
dire d'une platitude conformisme qui
nous ramène aux années 85
vous suivez vous suivez beaucoup la
première de la droite arrive je
m'intéresse à la politique je regarde le
fais partie des gens de gauche qui vont
aller voter pour alain juppé pour éviter
nicolas sarkozy
non non non non j'ai géré tant que
adversaires politiques mais j'ai du
respect et moi pour mes adversaires
politiques
je pense d'ailleurs c'est important d'en
avoir ils en ont pas toujours
elle se permet de dire que les propos de
monsieur le maire sont inqualifiables
j'aimerais dire qu'on ait le temps de
parler de dijon mais terminons sur
françois hollande
vous avez quand même des phrases un peu
on a lu dans la presse françois hollande
est un galet ça peut être un peut
interpréter à de double-face un peu à
double tranchant j'ai voulu ce que l'a
précisé oui j'aimerais y aller c'est un
roc
tout le monde voit qu'il a une
résistance incroyable vous savez faut
supporter ce qui supporte le holland
bashing qui qu'il subit depuis le début
de son quinquennat c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'on a rarement vu un
nicolas sarkozy n'était pas il n'a pas
été épargné à la fin de son mandat à la
fin de son mandat et françois hollande
il donc voilà un président qui est
honnête je me permettre l'indiqué pas
une affaire judiciaire pas un problème
d'argent
ça n'a pas été le cas des précédents
présidents je le rappelle à part le
général de gaulle mais maintenant tout
le monde fait référence à de gaulle j'ai
bien compris
en tous les cas c'est un président qui
est honnête qui fait son travail qui a
des résultats
donc il doit aller au bout il doit se
présenter là on peut avoir un doute sur
votre soutien on va voir quelques images
récemment emmanuel macron est venue à
dijon
surprise on a vu françois patriat et
françois patriat dans ce n'était pas une
surprise mais met à bôle la voix le
maire de lover et maire de samson et
vous qui embrasse et on a travaillé avec
mc rond on a travaillé ensemble pendant
vous le soutenez vers sa démarche
je vais vous dire je l ai déjà dit
d'ailleurs on a travaillé ensemble
pendant 17 mois
c'est quelqu'un de
de bienveillant et d'agréable et que
j'apprécie mais je soutiens françois je
les dis devant tout le monde
voilà mais ça peut compliquer cette
situation quand même moi je pense que si
françois hollande est candidat
j'espère que emmanuel macron soutiendra
françois hollande alors revenons-en à
dijon vendredi soir dans le quartier des
grésillés des pompiers des policiers ont
été visés par un cocktail molotov lancés
par des jeunes a priori alors est-ce que
selon vous ça justifie encore un peu
plus ces manifestations que l'on ne
cesse de voir deux policiers y en a eu
d'ailleurs vendredi soir également
non ça justifie pas les annonces de les
remarquer ça justifie pas les
manifestations il faut il faut
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans les forces de l'ordre et il faut y
répondre
mise l'intérieur a fait des propositions
mais il faut voir l'exaspération qui qui
gagne ces agents de sécurité ces forces
de l'ordre ce service public c'est pas
de la manipulation l'extrême droite
comme certains ont dit il peut y en
avoir mais je pense qu'il ya une vraie
exaspération
elle est due à des tâches extrêmement
difficile qu'on leur demande d'assumer
au fait que mais maintenant c'est devenu
quelque chose comme 1 et 2 connus ils
ont eu des diminutions formidable
d'effectifs sous nicolas sarkozy
12000 postes en moins que on a du mal à
recréer ces douze mille poste aussi
rapidement qu'on peut les supprimer vous
savez et ça il faudra s'en souvenir pour
la suite c'est long de recréer des
postes
ils ont été confrontés à beaucoup de
manifestations à des formes de plus en
plus dur de violence il ya des groupes
anarcho libertaire qui s'attaque à eux
et maintenant des voyous parce que c'est
pas des jeunes inquiétant j'espère
qu'ils seront arrêtés et sévèrement
punis sévèrement sanctionnés c'est
inacceptable c'est inacceptable gens
dire ici ils ont ma solidarité la plus
totale
ça ne leur suffit pas est ce qu'il leur
faut c'est aussi des mesures il faut
qu'il y ait moins de tâches indues
il faut se préoccuper plus de remettre
les agents dans les services publics et
sur la sécurité publique dans la rue ils
le savent ils l'attendent et donc il est
temps de s'y mettre
mais je vais pas pu le faire parce que
j'étais trop préparé voyez un peu du mot
est ce assez pour 30 réfugiés en
provenance de calais ça c'est de notre
actualité la semaine sont arrivés cette
semaine alors c'est rude et creusot à
dijon ils ont été installés vous êtes
allés sur place hier avec la préfète
il ya beaucoup de communication à autour
de ce démantèlement de la jungle de
calais de ce qu'on appelle la jungle de
calais du camp aussi de paris c'est pour
montrer que le gouvernement a enfin pris
ses responsabilités vous savez ils se
sont tous agglutinés là bas parce que
nicolas sarkozy a signé un accord avec
l'angleterre les accords de du touquet
ils font que la frontière anglaise l air
la frontière de la grande-bretagne
allait en france et donc après c'est
encore la faute de nicolas sarkozy oui
vous savez quand on assume le pouvoir
pendant 10 ans on a des conséquences
pendant dix ans qui continue et donc ça
ne disparaît pas comme ça et donc il a
fallu prendre une décision elle a été
prise à appliquer de manière je crois
juste avec moi j'ai lancé un appel des
maires solidaire pour que chacun prenne
sa part ce sont des gens qui ont fui la
guerre ce sont des réfugiés politiques
et donc le devoir minimum de solidarité
celle accueillir dans des conditions
dignes ces personnes ne peut pas les
laisser soit dans la boue soit sous les
ponts et donc j'ai voulu que la merde
certains refusent la ville de dijon
prenne ses responsabilités et elle a
fait installer 85 mobile homes lieu
d'accueil dans tous les cas de qualité
pour pour eux je ne touche pas
d'allocation particulière tu devrais le
dire ici à tous ceux qui m'envoient des
des postes sur ce thème là donc ce sont
des gens qu'il faut respecter qui ont
fui la guerre et il faut penser qu'ils
ont une réaction négative
souvent il ya aussi des réactions
positives fort heureusement d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs on voit que ceux qui
critiquent sont souvent un minoritaire
en la matière tant mieux mais ils sont
comme on dit deux forts en gueule vous
savez on les entend beaucoup ils font du
bruit mais ils font que du bruit
finalement ils ne font que du bruit
autre sujet votre projet de multiplexe
cinéma au sein de la cité de la
gastronomie vient d'être retoqué par la
commission départementale c'est un vrai
revers ce nom
non non ça c'est pas noël non ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle mais il ya des
obstacles ou ceux qui disent qu'ils
soutiennent la cité de la gastronomie
n'arrête pas de mettre des bâtons dans
les roues donc monsieur l'habitude il ya
monsieur message appelle monsieur
pétition vous savez il se reconnaîtra
monsieur pétition depuis 2001 il
s'oppose à tous les projets que j'avance
mais ils sortent tous le projet que je
fais il s'était opposé à la ligne où il
fallait qu'elle soit plus grand il
fallait qu'elle soit mieux fallait qu il
soit deux fois deux voies
il s'est opposé à la piétonnisation
fallait laisser la place à la voiture et
il s'est opposé à ce que je faisais pour
le commerce de centre-ville soit disant
ça allait mal etc etc
et là ils s'opposent à la cité de la
gastronomie il s'oppose au cinéma mois
et jusqu'à je voudrais vous dire ce que
je veux parce que je vais laisser les
ceux qui sont responsables de cette
proposition à savoir cinéduc madame
d'avoine et l eldorado s'expliquer je
veux pas le faire alors oui mais
pourquoi m expliquer pourquoi vous
voulez mettre des cinémas finalement au
milieu de la cité de la gastronomie pour
sauver le cinéma de centre-ville
je m'entraîne pour combien de temps
est-ce qu'il est aux normes d'accueil
des personnes handicapées
c'est pour les cd ils font absolument il
faut absolument que nous ayons des
salles accessibles au centre ville le
cinéma devosge n'est pas accessible
il va fermer de toute façon sauf à faire
des travaux qu'il est le propriétaire
madame d'avoine ne pourrait pas assumer
et puis les autres le dard ci doit être
mis aux normes
et puis là ce que les cas liés escaliers
mécaniques du gaumont et doit être
réparé il faut investir il faut et puis
food et il faut des films en vo aussi de
temps en temps c'est bien et donc il
faut des belles salles fonctionnelles et
donc moi je crois que c'est le meilleur
moyen de conforter le cinéma de
centre-ville qui restera au à l'hyper
centre savoir le d'arcy et le gaumont et
je ne l'autoriserait jamais tant que je
serai maire la création d'un multiplexe
à la toison d'or ça m'arrive d'aller
répéter je le répète tout le monde
comprend ça m'a été proposé plusieurs
fois je les ai toujours refusé parce que
je défends le cinéma de centre-ville
vous imaginez un maire qui je crois que
ça s'est appréciée de ses concitoyens
qui dirait je vais supprimer le cinéma
sur ta ville c'est le procès qu'on fait
comme si je voulais supprimer de cinéma
de centre-ville donc assez pour le
remettre
et le mien
le garde et on a compris alors l'autre
projet d'envergure un peu plus technique
s'est dit gens accèdent en 2018 au
statut de métropole oui alors le
gouvernement a présenté un texte qui
assouplit les règles alors le texte sera
examiné en séance publique à partir de
demain d'ailleurs au sénat rejettent la
commission des lois la route au pied sur
le sol mais aussi sonore ouais très
départementaliste le sommet à vous le
savez en même temps franchement n'est
pas une métropole de 250 4000 habitants
ce c'est légitime mais c'est dijon la
communauté humaine elle fait de 154000 à
10,1 mais le bassin d'emploi de dijon et
fait qu'elles sont vaines et l'habitante
420 mille habitants c'est ça la
véritable métropole pour des raisons
liées qu'amènera quoi aux citoyens
s'amènera quoi aux citoyens ça permettra
comment vous dire par capillarité de
faire pénétrer le développement
économique le rayonnement de la ville
dans l'ensemble du département c'est le
but que je me porte et plus largement
dans l'ensemble de la région
il n'est pas concevable qui est
aujourd'hui une grande région pour une
fois je comptais une grande région si à
paris une capitale régionale métropole
c'est le cas de la région centre avec
orléans et orléans obtiendra ce statut
et nous aussi
et nous on a déjà fait les grands pas en
avant parce qu'on est déjà communauté
urbaine et c'est là où il ya
l'intégration entre les communes et une
vraie communauté de destin entre les
communes
vous savez si j'avais pas eu des maires
défensif ou autour de nous deux elle
sera beaucoup plus grande
le bassin d'emploi de dijon et de
beaucoup plus grand les gens qui souvent
habite à genlis et c'était bien de
travailler à dijon c'est à dijon qui a
les emplois c'est dans la zone de dijon
qui a les emplois et donc moi je suis
prêt à accueillir jeu le forcé personne
mais j'ai vu ce qu'ils pouvaient se
faire ici ou là à asnières en défense
environ faire une petite communauté de
communes entre nous messigny et tout
c'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu de
demain
nous devons mettre toutes nos forces en
commun et c'est un appel pour que ce
n'est pas encore un peu plus de
centralisme de dijon comme le crâne aux
internautes qui nous a posé la question
non pas du tout pas du tout du
centralisme dijon c'est quoi 113 de
dijon ces charges de centralité
qu'assument les dijonnais c'est un bon
le chu sê c'est quelque chose du
centralisme être des gens l'université
c'est du centralisme
donc quand on a quand on est malade on
est heureux qu'ils aient le chu quand on
était une des enfants
ruch et une université de 32 mille
personnes
bref dijon est ouvert pour accueillir et
rayonner et permettent à ce département
de den osse sa productivité
il ne reste pas beaucoup de temps mais
je voudrais poser une autre question
d'un autre internaute
allez-vous passer la main aux prochaines
élections municipales il le verra vous
aviez dit trois ans la wii donc il devra
vous garderez la communauté urbaine où
la métropole on verra on verra
vous avez parlé d'un de vos adversaires
j'en ai un autre tout à l'heure on va
décrypter un cd françois xavier dugourd
là il y en a un autre
emmanuel oshoffa non monsieur pétition
celui cantonales d'immobiliser francs il
ya aussi emmanuel bichot qui annonce la
prochaine publication d'un livre noir
sur votre digestion ils dénoncent un
potentat local vous seriez un potentat
local
est ce que finalement il est pas un peu
comme vous à l'époque vous critiquez le
duc tout-puissant robert poujade est ce
que c'était un peu la même chose
j'ai toujours été respectueux lors de la
respectueuse mais vous critiquez j'ai
toujours été respectueux je n'ai jamais
fait un recours contre une décision
qu'il avait prise et j'ai toujours pensé
que parce que je lui succéderait je le
battrai où je lui succéderait il
faudrait assumer ce qui a précédé
est ce que ne comprend pas monsieur
bichot qui d'ailleurs est très peu
appréciée y compris par ses propres amis
tu es rejeté d'un peu partout
je le dis quand même qu'ils rejetaient
de partout par les propres sien ce
monsieur qui ne s'est pas présenté
lui-même à l'élection municipale
quand je vois ce qui fait je me dis que
c'est dommage pour la ville allez on
termine par cette citation de gandhi
donc vous disiez tout à l'heure le
bonheur c'est quand vos axes sont en
accord avec votre parole vous êtes sûr
d'avoir atteint ce bonheur là je pense
que je l'attendrai gelé atteint en
revenant à dijon et je les attends
emportant les projets que je porte pour
les dijonnaises et dégénéré merci franz
a même accepté notre invitation dimanche
en politique se poursuit juste après le
flash régionales et c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui est l'invité de francis le
bon dimanche à tous